I just want to start with the Sky News
tortoise investigation at Westminster
accounts into money in Westminster now
the SMP are calling for root and Branch
reform do you think the system needs it
no Lou I think the thing that's come out
of that to me is that all of this money
that people get is it is declared
um and it's all publicly available for
people to see and they're members of
parliament have to account for you know
where they take donations where they
earn income from outside then they have
to it's all publicly available they have
to be able to be transparent about you
know what they've taken what they've
been doing for it and that's how it
works and if they're and ultimately in
you know in our system if voters don't
like it they can boot them out and get a
new member of parliament I guess like
whatever where everyone agrees is the
need for transparency and the more
transparency has got to be a good thing
and one proposal that for example Eric
pickles the conservative peer uh chair
of the Watchdog one second job says
digested is that every donation should
perhaps be registered under someone's
actual name rather than a company that
people may or may not know who's behind
it I mean is that the kind of thing that
could be looked into well I'm very happy
if people want to look at some of the
detail I mean I think it is important
that people know if you know if MPS do
some outside work and that doesn't get
in the way of doing their job as an MP I
think it's important that MPS know what
their primary job is which is to
represent their constituents but if they
do something else as long as people are
clear about who's paying for it you know
and what work they're doing and we've
obviously tightened the rules up have
been tightened up on that over recent
years then I I think that's absolutely
fine and ultimately it's for MPS
constituents to look at the job they do
look at the information is declared and
make a decision at election time about
whether they want to keep them and I
guess the more information the better
yeah absolutely yeah no so I mean I
think if we look at proposals like that
those are ultimately for Parliament
rather than for government but you know
I think if people want to look at those
and bring proposals for then obviously
people will look at them in a in a you
know in an appropriate way
um let's talk strikes uh transport
Secretary of course you've had a busy
few months should we say
um now Mick Whelan the General Secretary
of the aslev train drivers union today
so that the possibility of a deal that
would of course avert strike action in
the future was Zero what would you put
it at well look I'm not going to put a
number on it but I thought you wouldn't
put it well I thought it was a bit
unfair because since I met Mick Wheaton
I mean he made a perfectly reasonable
point when I met him which is that his
Union hadn't been given an author yet
and obviously you're not in a position
to talk about it so I mean actually
things have actually moved on he's had
an offer he's in a position now where
his Union can sit down with the rail
delivery Group which represents train
operating companies and talk it through
talk through reform talk through the
money and there's at least a the basis
for a conversation there so you know
what I've tried to do since I got this
job was to I met the unions I've tried
to change the tone of the conversation
so that we're coming across as more
reasonable and I made sure that
um improved reasonable offers were made
to the trade unions on behalf of their
Workforce and you know we've we've made
some progress on on network rail the
tssa their leader was one of those
giving evidence that the select
committee today and unite have settled
with network rails we've made some
progress I'm going to say you know you
mentioned the tssa I mean what the rmt
would say to that is that they didn't
have the same issue when it comes to job
losses and changes to their working
conditions it was easier for them to
strike a deal well look these are the
sorts of things that have to be thrashed
out but they're part of the offer that
have been made it's partly on pay partly
on conditions but also there have been
some some guarantees now about no
compulsory redundancies
um for a period but it's for the it's
for the unions now to talk to the
employers and thrash out the detail and
I accept those details are important but
they've now got the space to do that I
get that you're trying to change the
tone to come across as reasonables and
it's non-confrontational but just a
couple of things to pick up on in what
you're saying you say you want the
unions to be neutral do you think that
they are not being neutral then no no
all I meant was this technical service
just the rmt when they put the first
deal to their members they recommended
their members reject it so so all we're
trying to get to we we're realistic to
think they probably won't go as far as
necessarily recommending it but we at
least want them to put it to their
members and say look here's a deal
you decide what to do we're not going to
tell you what to do and let their
members make a decision based on all the
facts at the beginning you said that you
thought Mick Whelan had been unfair in
putting the chances of a deal at zero do
you frankly think that some of the union
leaders are acting in good faith are
they playing to the cameras a bit do you
think no no I I I think it's not helpful
if if either they or I personalize it I
want to focus on the substance and the
reason why I said I thought he was being
unfair was just because things have
moved on you know an offer has now been
made
um you know so that he may not like the
offer and he may want it to be more or
whatever but an offer has been made so
we have made some progress there's
something now for his Union to debate
and talk about with the train operating
company so I think we need to make some
progress I I asked you a question about
good faith because it feels to me like
the union leaders are saying that you
are not acting in good faith I just want
to have a look at what Mick lyncher the
rmt said at the committee today he
suggested you deliberately let the
strikes go ahead over Christmas he said
they let the strikes go ahead over
Christmas they didn't lift the telephone
or lift a finger to get them off he's
implying isn't he that you deliberately
let the strikes go ahead over Christmas
to try and turn public uh public opinion
against industrial action no not at all
I was very clear because I I was
interviewed by a number of media
organizations before Christmas and I was
very clear I'd facilitated offers to go
to the trade unions I wanted them to sit
down with the employers talk through
those details look at the reform package
and try and get to a solution and not
have the strikes those strikes were not
just damaging for you know the workers
that lost income but they were
enormously inconvenient for not just for
people going to work and important
appointments but the hospitality sector
for example
reckoned that it costs them about two
and a half billion pounds in Lost
Revenue so if I could have avoided the
strikes happening I would have done if I
could have done some more to do that I
would have done so but I did what I
could do which is to make sure that we
had some offers on the table for the
unions and the employers to talk about
them and I'm pleased that that's what
they're now doing and I hope that we can
make some some progress there's another
thing that I struggled to get my head
around uh frankly right is it right that
the department for transport still pays
out money to the train operating company
companies during strike action so even
if there's no service they still get
money from the taxpayer well look the
way it works Post cover it is that
effectively you know we we don't have
the franchising model anymore we have a
system where the railway companies are
paid um you know by my department to
operate the service that exists because
the question is you know if that is the
case then there's they haven't really
got any incentive to reach a deal have
they they're going to get the money
whatever happens doesn't matter to them
if they're strikes or not well they get
paid to run the service but they do they
do want to solve these problems and
ultimately I want to solve these
problems because you know your viewers
may not realize this but you know since
covert the taxpayer has put a fortune
into the railway
points the money into the railways even
if there's no training yes no absolutely
and it's wonderful but it's one of the
reasons though why we need to settle
these disputes but we have to settle
them in the way that's fair both for the
passenger who is interested in how much
their fares are and whether their trains
are reliable but also the taxpayer there
isn't a bottomless pit of taxpayers
money I'm Keen to talk to you a bit
about the NHS as well because obviously
the transport is not the only sector
where strikes are going ahead we've seen
lots of strikes in the edge as well
nurses ambulance workers as well we'll
be talking to Pat Cullen of the Royal
College of Nursing after this interview
what's your message to her well look I
think two things I think first of all in
the NHS we have a way of dealing with
pay which is through these independent
pay review bodies
um and you know the government sets out
its position the unions are able to put
evidence to them and last year's pay
review body we accepted in full so that
you've got nurses who've got at least a
1400 pound payment we we know we play
this game we play this game for months
now you know you can overrule them if
you want to can't you yeah but we have a
process on purpose so so that it isn't
just about politics so we've accepted
those pay-per-view bodies and by the way
not every government in the past has
always accepted that we've accepted
those yeah
they've tended to do less not not more
what we've done this week which we
thought was a helpful piece of
transparency and discussion with the
unions was
um the pay review body the Secretary of
the State have got paid review bodies um
wrote to the uni leaders met them to
talk about the evidence that the
government's going to put into those
payroll is to talk to you is to
understand where there may be some
common ground and to look at the what
the pay-per-view bodies are going to be
doing for the coming Financial year and
we thought that was helpful but you know
ultimately the the initial ask of the
nursing Union was a was a pay rise of
RPI plus five percent that was close on
nine days
yeah but coming up with a very large
number and then saying you'll meet
someone halfway for something that's
still an inflation busting pay rise it
isn't affordable for the tax well
they're saying that around 10 which is
around and inflation yeah but it's not
affordable for the test it's not
inflation it's way more inflation by the
way than is the average in the private
sector which is more in the four or five
percent space so you know we've got to
be fair to Public Service workers you
know we value nurses which is why we
gave them a pay rise when there was a
freeze in the public sector but it's
also got to be fair for the people that
are paying their taxes in the private
sector who are getting much smaller
rights I do ask you
um you know we're seeing multiple
strikes across different sectors you
know almost every week There's a new
strike
um this is a government that or a prime
minister that is trying to model itself
as you know it's all about competence
yeah and if you can't get a grip on
these strikes you're failing to avert
them isn't that the definition of
incompetence no not at all look what
we're trying to do and the Prime
Minister set out his priorities uh last
week is about trying to halve inflation
this year now that doesn't happen
magically by itself it happens if you
take sensible policy decisions so look
the reason why there are more strikes is
very straightforward wood inflation has
been high not entirely but largely
driven by Putin's war in Ukraine which
has driven up Energy prices and food
prices that's had a knock-on effect so I
completely understand why people are
feeling under pressure but the problem
is if the government then just embeds
those higher pay rises in the system
we're not going to halve inflation this
year and if we're still here next year
with high inflation people we haven't
helped anybody people are struggling to
you know hit the thumb Heat their thumb
if people are struggling to heat their
homes feed their families you hear
stories about nurses going to food food
banks they're not going to be thinking
about embedding you know payroll that's
why we look that's why we wanted to make
Fair pay Rises which is why we've
accepted in full the pay-per-view body
recommendations that we've done that
that's also why the that we've got a
package of support for people to help
them with high energy prices so we
accept that people need help but you've
got to balance it and ultimately we want
to get to the position where we've
Harvard inflation we've driven it down
grow showing the economy and then people
will actually be and feel better off and
I think that's where we want to get to
at the end of this year just finally
because we are um out of time um
confirmed that he has used private
healthcare in the past he won't go as a
time period so we don't know if it was
10 years ago or 10 days ago should we
care
well I think the most important thing is
whether he's doing the right thing for
the NHS and you know he comes from an
NHS family his dad was a GP his mum was
a pharmacist and I judge him by what he
does and he's put you know the Autumn
statement when we had tough decisions to
take we put a significant amount of
extra resources into Health and Social
care to deliver on the ground I guess
that's maybe where some people's concern
is though you know will he do the right
thing by the NHS if uh you know we've
seen these huge waiting times for
ambulances for a e for operations for GP
appointments people may not trust that
he's going to do the right thing if he
doesn't understand what it's like for
most people well look I think he does
and that's why if you look at his
priorities he set out last week one of
them was about those weights for
elective operations the operations that
are planned which is why we've almost
got rid of anybody who's waiting for two
years in that that post-pandemic backlog
we're hoping to get that down to uh by
by March will have got rid of any work
body waiting more than 18 months and
then the plan is by next spring is we'll
have got rid of anybody having to wait
for more than a year but at the same
time we're putting more resources in
place to deal with accident and
emergency to get people out of Hospital
you don't need to be there into social
care that's why the Secretary of State
set out 500 million pounds another 250
million pounds an ounce this week so I
think you judge the government what it's
doing we're focusing on accident
emergency we're focusing on elective
recovery post pandemic and I think
that's how the Prime Minister will be
judged and he set those priorities out
clearly in his speech last week okay
thank you very much pleasure